Hello, my name is Chief
Han. I'm the president of the link and ring stage
.
The denominator, Lou, doesn't study.
You can use these words and phrases to
talk when you have
time.The sounds are the same.You
can study in a natural way.Adults can
learn faster than babies,
because adults can speak a lot in their own words.
35 I already have it, and I can
read it, and adults can
use the link system.
Read and save the necessary words and phrases
and
study using Subayashi instead.
At that time, please talk with my niece that you are a
native speaker, and
write your essay and submit it to
, and
I will wait for Hayashi.  Temasu Rin
I can speak English and other foreign languages ​​for friendship
.